This video is brought to you by Squarespace.
Whether you need a do mean website or online store maker with Squarespace,
check out squarespace.com for a free trial link in the description below kidney
or pulled the second ruled over Belgium from 1865 to 1909 today.
The memory of his reign still lives on and he is glorified with golden statues
of his likeness in every major city in Belgium.
In history class,
each generation is taught that he was a humanitarian.
He brought Christianity and the wonders of civilizations of the Congo Free
State.
However,
the truth has been kept away from the Belgium people.
The reality is the king Leopold.
The second is responsible for the murder and mutilation of 10 million Congolese
people.
In the video today we're looking at what might just be the biggest cover up in
European history.
Leopold.
The second was born in 1835 to king Leopold the first and is Luisa.
Maria Volley on.
They were the very first role family of Belgium because the country,
it was just five years old for thousands of years.
That territory had been conquered by nearby the Netherlands,
France,
Germany,
and Luxembourg.
They were a newly independent country.
There's had to get to form a unique national identity.
Leopold,
the seconds had two younger siblings called Felipe and Charlotte.
Their family life was dysfunctional to say the least.
Soon after Charlotte's birth in 1844 king Leopold,
the first metric at 16 year old girl named [inaudible].
He was 54 years old at the time,
but that didn't stop him from having an affair with a teenage girl.
Clarence would go on to become a barren s and her son's George and Arthur were
made into barons.
They weren't rumors that the uphold the first ad to several other affairs,
so the exact number of half siblings that the appalled.
The second has is actually a known Queen Louise.
Maria was understandably miserable in a marriage and she chose to let out her
anger on her children.
She would make fun of young Leopold.
The second's large knows that he inherited from his father.
She told her son that his face was disfigured and that he had the beak of a bird
in 1853 when he was 18 years old,
Leopold the second had an arranged marriage with Marie Henry out of Austria
since he had never actually seen what a loving marriage looks like.
The team couple were incredibly awkward around one another.
Someone in the Belgium rock ought had commented that seeing them together,
it was like watching a nun and the stable boy people thought the best was so
hilariously accurate that the phrase was repeated amongst everyone who knew
them.
Apparently his parents cad so less about Leopold that they never even bothered
to tell them about the birds and the bees.
They're polled Zealand.
Queen Victoria of England had a great marriage with our husbands,
Albert and she apparently gave her nephew a lot of sacs advice.
This was probably just as awkward as you are right now in engineering.
They uphold the seconds and Marie Henry as eventually figured it out because
they managed to have two daughters together.
When Leopold the first dies in 1865 Leopold the seconds ascended the throne as
the new king of Belgium.
Since this personal life was so dysfunctional,
it's really no surprise that his happiness and satisfaction came from attaining
material thinks according to William the second the ruler of Germany,
he was together watching a parade with Leopold the second in Berlin when he
called and said there is really nothing left for us king's except money.
Before he died,
king Leopold the seconds father and made 50 attempts to conquer a colony for
Belgium,
but he always failed.
It was clear to him that the power of other countries like England,
France,
Germany,
and the United States was thanks to colonization there pulled the first belief
that without colonizing an African nation,
they would never be considered one of the world's larger powers.
Leopold,
the second's picked up where his father left off,
but he did not want to conquer a nation on behalf of Belgium.
He blends to make an entire country is personal property.
This way he could have complete control and to have direct access to the
profits.
He knew that if he was honest about his greedy intentions,
none of the other major powers would agree to last him colonize an entire
country for himself,
so he simply told everyone that it was his mission to spread Christianity,
do the Congo.
He wanted to convert and civilize.
There's poor godless souls.
In 1884 he met with 14 other European nations at the Berlin conference.
He pitched his idea for colonizing the Congo and cleaned that he wanted to spend
his own fortune bringing missionaries to Africa out of the goodness of his own
heart.
He also promised the rest of Europe that they could freely explore and trade
with his country.
The Congo,
though it was known for being incredibly dangerous and difficult to colonize the
rain forest and Savannah,
they're filled with gorillas,
lions,
leopards and wolves.
The Congo river has Manny's in crocodiles and hippopotamuses as well as insects
that carry deadly diseases in general.
It was a very wild place and not many Europeans exactly wanted to go out there
and live.
If they're bought the second one you to go and take on the challenge.
The other powers were pretty much willing to say,
well,
go on then.
Oh,
well,
she explorer in journalist named Henry Morgan.
Stanley already had years of experience in Africa.
He was sent on projects by several different newspapers in the United Kingdom
and he became an expert on the continents.
Through his writing,
he tried to convince Queen Victoria that despite all of the difficulty he
believed it would be worthwhile to colonize the Congo.
Here's suggestions and ever made any impact until king Leopold.
The seconds found his work.
In 1879 the king sent him on a mission to colonize the Congo.
Henry Martin Stanley used parlor tricks.
Do you convince the African tribal chiefs that white men were invincible?
He used a battery powered contraptions and makers grips so strong that Congolese
men almost collapsed from a single handshake.
Sadly,
claims that white men could wrap a tree out of the grounds with their bare
hands.
He also held a magnifying glass in the sunlight and use the sun's rays to light
a cigar,
claiming that to man had power over the sun.
Finally,
he handed the gun to a need of men.
He instructed him to step back several yards and try to shoot him sounded he had
taken the gunpowder and bullets out beforehand,
of course,
and it's when the young man build the trigger.
Stanley would double over dramatically only to take his shoe off and shake the
bullet out onto the grounds.
He claims that white men were spirits who could not be killed and no matter how
hard they it and the two bullets which simply pass right through them.
This was enough to terrify the chiefs into signing a contract which declared
king Leopold the seconds for new owner of the Congo.
Of course,
the Congolese people had no idea what the contract actually says,
but it served as a legal document in the eyes of the European people.
Now,
Leopold's wants to keep up an image that he was doing good in the country,
so he named it the Congo Free State.
Henry Morgan Stanley published a book about his journey through Africa called
through the dark continent.
He was able to go on a lecture tour around London and he was even knighted in
Leopold the second Trudy was paying for all of the startup expenses do colonize
the Congo out of his own pockets.
He appointed governor generals to manage the various territories of the country.
Leopold's men eventually discovered that the rain forest had a plentiful supply
of rubber trees.
This,
it was essentially like stumbling across a gold mine.
At the time.
There was a huge demand for natural rubber in order to make tires,
but there was a very small supply.
The only problem of course,
was finding a way to pay for all of the manual labor required the bolder
seconds.
Well,
he ordered his men to enslave the Congolese people.
Each of the governor general's had their own tactic to achieve this.
Usually they set a village on fire so that there was no worth anyone's a height.
They would shoot and capture women of the village and tell them that if they did
not bring back 15 kilograms of rubber,
by the end of the day,
they would kill their wives and daughters.
The Congo free state was anything but free.
King Leopold.
The second believe that all of these people were his personal slaves and he
could do whatever he wanted with them.
King Leopold passenger,
he handed out bonuses to the commanders if they could produce more rubber by any
means necessary.
Leopold's began to grow his own private army in the Congo called the force
publique.
When his men were destroying villages,
they would pick out the tool list and strongest young men to recruit as
soldiers.
These soldiers were instructors do systematically kill anyone who disobeyed the
orders of the governor generals.
They were told to not waste any ammunition and that they must kill a man with a
single bullet.
They were required to bring back one severed hand for every bullet fired.
If they did not,
they would be killed by that general.
This led to the soldiers cutting off hands of people that were still alive
whenever they wasted ammunition.
Meanwhile,
in Europe,
people have no idea what was actually going on.
Word got around that King Leopold,
the second neater more soldiers to help with his Christian missions.
You colonize the Congo,
hundreds of young men from Belgium,
Italy,
Norway,
Sweden,
Denmark,
they all signed up to join the force.
Publique.
They were taught that these black natives worth animals and not fully human like
them,
so they shouldn't guilty about killing them whenever necessary.
After a while,
these men,
they became desensitized to the killing.
Some of these soldiers would Gus people learns,
pull out that end trails or slice off a group of men's genitalia only to hang
them in a row.
Some of the Governor General's right,
that is to King Leopold.
The second about the scenes because they were actually proud of their brutality.
They believed that the worst they treated the Congolese people,
the harder they worked.
Overtime King Leopold's men managed to enslave the entire population of the
country even though we'd promise that the rest of the world could visit the
Congo whenever they want.
Since King Leopold,
the second's became very nervous when he learned that Arabian merchants were
coming together,
some rubber for themselves.
He did not want to lose his monopoly over the industry,
so he declared that they needed to go to war with these so called Arab slave
traders,
which would free the Congolese people.
The sparks,
the two year Congo,
Arab war and 95 and English merchant named Charles Stokes was on a mission for
the Germans do travel to the Congo to purchase.
Rather,
he was hung by the force Republique with out receiving a trial,
Germany and Britain,
they were outraged that he was killed without ever committing any crime.
The of Holt was forced to pay substantial fines to both governments for
violating the treaty,
and the incident was cooled.
The stokes Afaf,
however,
paying this fine,
it was a drop in the bucket.
King Leopold the second made a profit of 220 million francs,
which would be worth more than a billion dollars today
liberal.
The second time,
the team of propaganda writers to publish books and articles about what a great
job he was doing.
None of these writers had ever actually traveled to the Congo free stage,
but they were happy to glorify their kings,
Christy,
and mission.
However,
journalists from Great Britain and the United States were beginning to travels
the Congo Free State and report on what they saw in the air.
As in 19 Americans have a war veteran named George Washington Williams visited
the Congo Free State and he was horrified.
He wrote an open letter to King Leopold.
The seconds are counting the horrors that he witnessed while visiting the
country.
The king,
he never replied.
A man named Edelman's Denny moral worked as a clerk at a shipping firm in
Liverpool.
Linkedin's Belgium ships would come and go delivering rubber to Liverpool from
the Congo mural knew that it wouldn't be possible for Belgium to produce such a
high volume of rubber and less they were using slave labor.
He began investigating and when he discovered the horizontal,
what was actually happening,
he wrote several anonymous articles for a British newspaper called the speaker
exposing the truth about what he saw.
He wrote,
this was the greatest crime that has ever been committed in the history of the
world.
In 1901 the shipping company offered moral a job to manage the shipments of
rubber to and from the Congo.
They were willing to pay him a huge salary in exchange for his silence.
He turned it down and became a full time journalist and stat.
It became so passionate about the cause that he began publishing his own
newspaper,
called the west African male with any new information he founds.
In 1906 he published a book called Red Rubber and other journalists name's Roger
Casement,
was sent to interview people of the Congo to get their testimonies about the
human rights abuses in the country.
He realized that it was crucial to convince the White Christian missionaries to
come forward with their stories because they had been there from the beginning
and they could prove that king Leopold.
The second was aware of the atrocities after Roger casements report was
published,
King Leopold,
the second he knew that if he did not respond with his own inquiry,
this would be the end of him.
He sent his own international commission to the Congo in the hopes that he could
bribe them.
He thought that he could pay them off to publish whatever he wanted them to say,
but this totally backfired and Christy and missionary named John Harris had been
living in the Congo Free State for years.
He and his wife devoted their lives to helping me,
Congolese people.
When King Leopold's international commission showed up,
John Harris was ready for them.
He gathers a group of Congolese people who testified to the death,
torture,
mutilation,
rape,
and then save them that they suffered at the hands of the king.
His wife,
Alice Harris,
was a photographer and she was able to present them with photographic evidence
of the horse that they had seen.
When the international commission returned to Belgium,
they published a 50 page report on all the human rights abuses that they had
found in the Congo.
They submitted it to king there,
Paul,
the seconds once he realized that he could no longer get away with his lies,
Leopold audit,
all of the Congo free state records to be burned so that there would be no
evidence of his crimes.
In 19 eight the Congo became a Belgium colony,
but they didn't seize it from the king.
Instead,
they paid him 50 million francs for the purchase.
He dies just one year later in 1909
once the Belgium government visited the Congo,
they found far more profitable resources than just rubber.
They were diamonds,
gold,
and ivory that could be sold for massive profits.
The government ended slavery and employed the Congolese people to work for wages
instead very soon after Belgium became extremely wealthy,
the city of Brussels.
Now some of the most breathtaking architecture in the world is complete with
golden statues of King Leopold.
The seconds,
all because of the money that he brought from the Congo,
but the Belgium government,
they had to make a decision.
What do they tell if a public Leopold the second line to his people for a long
time and they looked up to him like a father figure who brought glory to the
country.
Not only would the citizens be disappointed,
but it would make Belgium look terrible to the outside world.
Their nation was still less than a hundred years old at the time.
England in the United States had already outlawed slavery in the 18 hundreds so
the king of Belgium had essentially taken a big step backwards in humanitarian
progress.
The Belgium government chose to allow their people to continue believing the lie
that King Leopold the second to built for himself,
they taught their children that there was never any slavery in the Congo.
Free stays in that everything king Leopold.
The second did was wonderful.
This lie was retold generation after generation,
so the point we're at became then you truth and part of that cultural identity.
Before his death in 1897 the apple of the created a human zoo at his summer
estate.
He bolts and muddle African village and captured to 267 Congolese people to live
that Belgium people showed up to Gawk at them throwing peanuts and bananas over
the fence as if they were monkeys.
They were forced to stay outdoors in this village and all kinds of weather.
Several of those people dying of influenza and pneumonia after he died to the
king's estates became the Royal Museum of Central Africa and to continue to
glorify Leopold.
The seconds achievements in colonization decades after his death in 1958 the
governments of Belgium even went as far as to replicate is human zoo at the
Brussels welfare,
putting Congolese people on display like animals.
Once again,
nearly every western nation has some history of slavery and genocide,
but in most Belgian school classes they will never have the truth about king
Leopold.
The seconds they will say that slavery never happened in the Congo since the
records were destroyed.
We will never know just to many people,
Leopold was responsible for killing some estimate that it is roughly 4 million
while others believe it is as high as 10 somewhere between 70 to 90% of the
total population was wiped out in the age of the Internet.
It does.
It become much more difficult for Belgium to ignore the reality of what happens.
In 2018 the curators of the Royal Museum of Central Africa finally decided to
change the exhibits to honor the lives lost by the native Congolese people.
However,
Congolese people who've visited the exhibits said that it is still not enough
and that as long as the story is told from the perspective of a Belgium white
person,
the country will never show you the full truth about the monstrous deeds of King
Leopold.
The seconds.
So in some way the Internet has become an incredible way for smaller voices to
be heard and if there is something your passionate about and you want to share
it with the world,
well Squarespace is an amazing platform to do that on.
Squarespace allows you to create a beautiful online website and it's also
perfect if you're looking for a website for yourself or for maybe a business
that you want to start.
It all starts on Squarespace with a great looking template.
They have a ton to choose from really something to suit all tastes.
You can either start from scratch or easily move over and existing domain,
making everything super easy to manage.
And once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there's no upgrades,
there's no patches,
there's no tech bs to deal with.
No one likes all of that stuff.
But you know what everyone does like that would be Squarespace has 24 slash
seven customer support.
They're there to help you whenever you've got a question.
And Squarespace isn't just about an online presence.
You can also totally sell stuff or services on a square space site that if
you're looking to share a message,
start a business,
pursue a dream,
Cetera,
do it with Squarespace,
head to squarespace.com for a free trial,
and when you're ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash buyer graphics and you'll save 10% off your
first purchase of a website or domain.
So thanks again to Squarespace for sponsoring this video.
Do check them out through the link below and as always,
do channel some of our other videos and link to on the screen now.
And as always,
thank you for watching.